i mean these pictures of elon musk
though
yeah
like damn
damn
like holy [ __ ] he he he looks like one
of these like ai images yeah like what's
the [ __ ] everyone's using dolly he looks
like a dolly image like yo give me elon
musk on a boat and it's like
and it just comes out all weird looking
like just sort of strange
he looks like raw chicken man i
and that's the cheap roast that's the
cheap rose i can't even claim that is
like unique but he genuinely does look
like raw chicken
like they just plucked his [ __ ] he's a
big [ __ ] man he is he's built
like a neanderthal yeah i love everyone
kind of like tiptoeing around like just
being super on the nose about body
shaming
yeah like just even more alarming from
this side but not what not not getting
into specifics about what's alone yeah
just pretentious man from the side this
is alarming
yeah yeah it is disturbing calling him
calling his body disturbing is so [ __ ]
up
and i and this is coming from a guy just
saying it looks like raw chicken but
i'm i'm not a good person
but i'm saying like
yeah when i looked at it i really had to
resist
like
oh yeah it looks like that filter on
snapchat the crazy one truly one of the
most disturbing images that's so [ __ ]
man i don't agree with that one i don't
agree with that one i you know i imagine
you're like having fun on a yacht it's
like the best day ever oh hold on let me
imagine having fun on a yacht
i can not i can picture it you can after
that
and then you like open
twitter yeah people just going yeah just
a like
yeah like from a long distance away a
paparazzi shot of you and
shirtless and someone's like this is the
most [ __ ] up thing i've ever seen
you're like
oh god damn yo yo yo
yo [ __ ]
look
hey you got that car accident body he's
got like zero percent body fat on his
back but he's wearing it all in the
front yeah how does he do it
i mean when i when i saw that image of
his dad you know that whole headline
like he got his like step daughter yeah
what the [ __ ] was that hey man
they got some interesting philosophies
in that family bro oh my god and then
like the quotes were so disturbing yeah
and being like yeah i you know i dated
her like when i was dating her mother
for
20 years blah blah blah and it's like
how are you so casually talking about
this the fact that you dated her mother
for 20 years
raised her and then started sleeping
with her
that's so [ __ ] yeah
yeah there's a lot of odd
things going on in that family if you
don't know what we're talking about
his dad elon musk's dad
impregnated his daughter-in-law
daughter-in-law that was just
step-daughter
sorry step-daughter yeah step-daughter
feel like he remarried he remarried
and then divorced the mother and started
dating the mother's daughter and then
impregnated her as grim
as grim
unplanned child and he's 76 and she's
35. oh
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
well you know i'm just a yeah i'm just a
little beta cuck
comedian 160 pounds who might have
talked [ __ ] yeah
yo you know what i finally finished
stranger things this week and we can't
talk about it because you don't [ __ ]
watch tv past seven yeah sorry was it
good why do you do that to yourself
how do you watch so much
you just [ __ ] give up your friends
and hobbies yeah it's because you're
you're doing that 9 30 [ __ ] yeah
because the time is in the morning
that's when the time is good you can't
watch stranger things at that time go to
sleep at eleven wake up at seven
no
i don't like that
this pervert likes to wake up at five
nine thirty to five
forty five you're a sick [ __ ] no but
that's the best hour of the day
is from like six to eight those are the
best hours oh i agree that's just like
pete there's nothing it's peaceful well
anyways look
stranger things that [ __ ] could have
been four episodes really i did not
uh sign up for 11 year old avengers
endgame okay
like by the end these dudes these kids
the kids are getting hit with [ __ ]
bottles
and doing like wing chun like
long combat scenes
you know
getting their [ __ ] eyes blown out
being blind like i don't i don't i don't
want to die i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on the half the series is
it's that
like the homeless chick yeah this is
millie bobby brown i can't and then she
cries
and then it's this other like nutsack
looking dude being like
yeah with his [ __ ] good hand with his
freddy krueger hand
he just
and then it cuts to 11.
and then in between you have like these
other kids being like
that's the nutsack looking dude yeah
yeah so what sound does he make
[ __ ] you in the ass okay
and the kids are like
yeah
and uh he's got all these like tentacles
all over the place
and then in the middle of it they're
just alluding to or not alluding but
like calling back the fact that one of
the main characters has been gay the
whole time um
it'll be like uh who is that it's will
will yeah or no who's the actor
uh the kid no schnapp no schnapp yeah
well i saw like a twitter moment or some
[ __ ] where he was like yeah my
character's been gay the whole time yeah
nice i th i thought i for sure
anticipated like
way more memes about him like i just
imagined frames of him and then p people
putting parentheses being like stairs
gaily or something like that yeah
yeah it's these random moments where
he's just like looking
he's just sad
you're like what the [ __ ]
that's like really that's a really
depressing thing to insert in the middle
of like what's supposed to be like this
i don't know fun like
80s retro monster movie it's like oh
here's a kid very sad in the closet
oh [ __ ] yeah
did you turn the captions on to make
sure that it says yeah it says stairs
gay character stares yeah gay character
looks in the distance
vaguely gay character you know yeah
what's your official review
um it just took too [ __ ] long just i
was just like a five it's just good
background [ __ ] but
the
so many like bad guy monologues
like in in 90s fashion where like
someone is on the verge of death and
then someone goes into this 15 minute
like i was playing the whole time you're
like oh
at the end of the month or just kill her
at the end of the monologue he realizes
that she's dead yeah and she's been dead
the whole time oh
because she wasn't even listening yeah
you took too [ __ ] you choked her out
stupid
there's a point where three of the
characters are like they get snatched up
by these tentacles and they're like
being choked to death
that lasts like a whole episode i mean
they should be [ __ ] dead by now right
that would have brought it home for me
if if like the tentacle was released and
three of them just like like hit the
ground and they're like yeah
four characters are gone i've been like
oh
hell yeah okay yeah at the very end
uh
like when hopper like meets 11 i [ __ ]
picked up the remote i'm just like
i'm just i'm watching the movie through
the little
i love doing that fast forward
but i loved it yeah no i'm with you on
that's my
it's my favorite way to watch a movie on
fast forward through the little box on
my iphone yeah so the box is like this
big
just scrolling across the screen yeah
yeah
yeah no audio no
on my apple watch
scrubbing the tiny little box
just so ass man
they just milked it
so much dialogue and struggle for
[ __ ] what
just for them to win
yeah you know
when they when like one of the
characters like they were like killing
her ass like
i'm like
oh okay
some real consequence here
no
in the hospital
she didn't die no
if they killed her right there i'd have
been like
so that's what would this would make the
show good for you
yeah because if there's real kids
that always makes a
okay
if there's any real consequence from
their you know
because i feel like that it's gone too
long now mm-hmm and this was like the
final boss of all the
someone should have gone to the grave
yes i'm saying so no one dies not really
so it's like the opposite of yellowstone
yeah
which i still need to watch
i just can't get past that [ __ ]
course really a spoiler it's just
something someone dies every single
episode
yeah sorry well no i'm not gonna watch
it you ruined it
i think character that you come to love
dies
every single one but that's great
because when you're going into it you're
like okay at some point all of these
people will die yeah
it's just a matter of when figuring out
when yeah that's the art in it all
exactly